so now i'm back in new york in 84 and i
would go over there
and pick up blow from time to time but
then the trip started becoming more
like instead of going once a week i
would go two times a week
three times i was popping i was in the
neighborhood
you know i was at the library you know
and meanwhile i was coked up and she'd
go what do you need and i go give me an
eight ball to take back
they're gonna give me cash i'll buy my
school books i wasn't even going to
[__] school
my whole relationship with this lady was
based on a lie you know
and uh something happened one day like
in july or august that year
that i hit her up for an ounce like i
was out of my [__] birth
and i need an ounce of rock these
[__] and she goes alright come
get it
bring me back to the 1100 or whatever it
was [__] you i never brought it back
but that's what i thought of it like i
never brought the money back like that's
how [__] piece of [__] i was like i
it was eleven hundred dollars i could
have sold 11 grams at 100
a piece still snorted 17 grams that's a
lot of coke to snort by myself
and still had her money but i decided i
was gonna beat her for eleven hundred
dollars what a p
what a [__] lunatic i was i had lost
my job by that time at the bar
at the bar i had no work and all i was
doing was
uh keeping this apartment and snorting
coke i had been suspended
and that's all i was doing guys was
going to a bar drinking all day and
snorting [__] coke and
i didn't know what the [__] so i had no
job no nothing a buddy of mine got me a
job
in the daytime like a warehouse clerk i
got fired from there after two weeks
and then i something it was five you
know when uh
when you lose somebody a close member in
your family or something
sometimes you mourn him right away or
that person but for the most part when
you're young like i was 16 my mother i
didn't mourn nobody
after a couple years i started realizing
what had happened
and that pain really started entering my
heart so the addiction i didn't and
listen
in 84 nobody knew coke was addicted
people would say you could snort what
you want ain't addictive
[__] it's addictive
you know in 84 when nobody really knew
that you lose your house and your wife
and your car
nobody had really gotten stung yet you
know so nobody really [__] knew but i
was living it and i didn't know it knew
the phone i said he didn't tell you i
knew it if i would have known i would
have done something about it
i didn't know [__] so it was weird i was
dating this girl and
we had broken up or something i didn't
really like the girl she was just a part
of my addiction
it was just the whole [__] deal the
addiction the blow her
it was all the same [__] we're still
friends by the way she's on facebook
i mean we're still friends and i liked
her but i didn't love her you know and i
would end up marrying her just to
[__] warmth we all make mistakes and
i would have done something stupid like
that
but that year like in by august of 84
i was halfway there you know and i was
trying to feel bad about the debt and
i thought i had this money coming to me
i had this will there was no [__]
will
i had nothing coming to me i had dick it
was all my mind [__] you know
so i'm sitting eating cuban food one day
in this neighborhood in this cuban
neighborhood
and this guy comes in he goes you coco
donors son of my gays
people looking for you in miami here's
this number call him and there was this
guy that was friends with my mother and
i called him up and he goes hey where
you been i want to see you
and i go where are you he goes in miami
come on down you know go to the airport
i'll send you money and i'm like oh my
god i'm about to walk into a [__]
coke ring
you know what i'm saying like i needed
help but no this is what was showing up
in my life at this time
so i go to miami and i'm talking to him
i'm telling him i need money and help
and he goes start taking back these
little [__] boxes they were like uh
you ever get like a pendant from [__]
one of those things
it was like a gold chain but then there
was like an ounce condensed
in coconut he says put them on your
luggage they'll think it's jewelry
so i started doing that [__] but in the
meantime one of those trips
i hooked up with [__] my like a
distant cousin in miami
that we were tight as children and then
something happened and we lost
uh the uncle went to jail or something
so we lost contact with them
and they're like why don't you come live
with us and this is what i was
at this time guys i just needed a
breather i needed 1500 hours to get my
life situated
and i could move on and never be in
jersey and try to be a natural human
being like just a normal human being
like you [__] here tonight
but no something i just wanted to get in
trouble so i asked
this uncle i go yeah i could stay with
you guys and sure enough
after like four days they knew i was
doing coke with my cousin and i'm like
20. he's like 17. he was doing more coke
than me at the [__] time
so they blamed it on me and like you got
to go so i got pissed off i'm like you
throwing me the [__] out when i need you
the most [__] you [__]
so i go let me pack and they're like get
the [__] out blah blah blah so on the
way
out i'm going in his room because i had
my like gel and all that [__] in his
room my
toothbrush and as i'm walking out i've
seen like a gold watch
so i stole the [__] gold watch
because i didn't have money to get back
home i had to cope to get home
but i didn't have the money for the
plane ticket that afternoon to get home
so i pawned the [__] gold watch in
miami it gave me the
money to get home i couldn't believe i
robbed my [__] uncle
and i went back to new york with the
coke sold it
and then my plan was to go back to miami
unpawn the watch and put it back in his
house sneak it back in
that was my cocaine plan
but like two days later they called me
like we know you stole the watch
so i was [__] anyway so i actually
went and picked up the watch but just
brought it back to jersey instead of
dropping it off
because they already knew and i felt
terrible about it like this
especially this guy his name was rodolfo
i was always very tight with him and he
was very tight with my real dad growing
up in cuba
and he was telling me stories about them
growing up and i loved them but just the
fact that he threw me out
for snort and coke they started [__]
coke and that's why i said to go rodolfo
how long have you been snorting [__]
coke he's like that doesn't matter
you can't do it in my house
he's like my wife found out so now you
got to go so it really hurt me that
these were
this is my family this is i needed these
[__] people
but i didn't understand what i had done
so i went back to miami i picked up the
[__] watch
and i'm wearing the watch now i'm a big
shot it's like a seiko with the diamonds
around it
and this gold band it was like a [__]
10 000 watch